Biden visited Selma Alabama yesterday on
the anniversary of the Civil Rights
march known as Bloody Sunday civil
rights leaders joined the president
marching across the Edmund Pettus bridge
where police and state troopers attacked
voting rights demonstrators 58 years ago
Mr Biden called for new government
action to protect the right to vote
right to vote to have your vote counted
as the threshold of democracy and
Liberty
with it anything's possible
without it without that right nothing is
possible
and this fundamental president pointed
to a Supreme Court case from Alabama
that could weaken the Voting Rights Act
that decision is expected by the end of
June